عبر حسابه على انستجرام الذي يضم اكثر من
ربع مليون متابع يتصور المصمم الرقميه
الهنديه
عالما موازيا بالذكاء الاصطناعي يتساءل
هذا الفنان في اعماله ماذا لو كان زعماء
العالم فنانين موسيقيين وماذا لو عاشت
فتاه الموناليزا في المدن الكبرى حاليا
ماذا يتساءل ايضا كيف ستبدو دول الخليج
اذا هطلت فيها الثلوج وكيف سيبدو ولا
سماثله اذا اعد وجبات السحور في رمضان
الفنان الهندي مشاهدينا في ضيافتنا اليوم
سيطلعنا على طريقه عمله وكيف ينتج الذكاء
الاصطناعي الفن النهائي
طيب
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الفنانه الرقمي
اهلا بك صباح الخير صباح الخير
يعني اتخيل ويل سميث يعمل سمبوسه جبن صعبه
لكن هل هذا يعتبر
فن هل نستطيع ان نطلق عليه فن من غير ريشه
مجاني
الى الوراء في العمل الماضي ثلاث مشاريع
احدهما احدهما كيف نتخيل هطول الثلج في
دبي وكيف ستكون دبي الخضراء
وكيف يمكن ان تكون هناك مستعمره اماراتيه
على المريخ
كنا عم نشوف دبي الثلوج قبل قليل
هذا العام
سعاده ساعدني الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهي الرحله اسميتها رحله
استطيع
انا فنان ايضا واستطيع ان نتخيل بعض الصور
في سياقات مختلفه يعني كيف يمكن التمييز
ما بين لوحه مرسومه بطريقه تقليديه بريشه
واحساس فنان ولوحه اخرى مرسومه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي زي ما انت يعني
انا رسام وارسم باليد
منذ 18 عاما كنت ارسم على الجدران وتم
عندما دخل الفوتوشوب انتقلت الى العالم
الرقمي ثم
الذكاء الاصطناعي ايضا انتقلت انتقالات
اخرى
وانتقلت الى التقنيات الجديده دائما كي
تحسن من ادائي
الادوات الجديده تعطي حياه
للصوره
فان نظرنا سوره كريستيانو رونالدو رونالدو
[موسيقى]
في الصوره
وهي تضع فيها الحياه وتصبح متقدمه يعني
الشق الاول من السؤال كيف افرق ما بين
الاصلي وما بين الذكاء المستخدم في هذه
الصور وهل بالتالي انا استطيع ان اكون
فنان مثلك من السهوله
لذلك سيكون هناك ارباك في المستقبل
التكنولوجيا ستتجاوز الحدود
نفكر بسوء استخدامها بل كيف يمكن ان نصنع
بها اشياء تسعد الناس لهذا
كره القدم
يغني الان
ما الذي تريده ما هي الرساله اللي حاب
توصلها الى الناس عبر هذا الفن
اكلي
فكرتوا فيها ان هؤلاء العمالقه ليسوا على
قيد الحياه وبالتالي لابد ان يفكر بهم
الناس ويتذكروهم
مهاتما غاندي لانهم كانوا فعلا هذه الارض
يوما ما وبالتالي وعنده بعض الحياه لهذه
الشخصيات هذه هي فكرتي حتى
الافكار المجنونه التي خرجته فيها سابقا
هي هاي شغف وهوايه وليست مجال عملك
الرئيسي انا حابه اني اشوف كمان من الصور
جيفارا هي موسيقي ايضا شيء جيفارا
اي نمر هذا
بشركه خاصه والوقت الحراميه
لكنها ستاتي
ربما مساء اليوم لكنها عندما تاتي افعلها
فورا لا افكر
ايلون ماسك
انا اريد يعني صوره لتذكر راويه مستقبلا
في
الصباح العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات